dieses spiel ist unmöglich macht ich bin
schon wieder tot hallo mein name ist
luca und herzlich willkommen zu einem
spiel was noch schlimmer als german
träsch ist dieses spiel heißt jump box
das ist die grafik ist tatsächlich dies
scheiße ich wollte allerdings germany
desch hier auf meinem handy zocken
allerdings habe ich nicht hingekriegt
das ganze irgendwie mit der elgato zum
laufen zu kriegen weil ich damit
irgendwie wollte nicht klar komme
deswegen habe ich noch alternativen
geschaut und habe jump box gefunden wir
kriegen einfach mal space for help
ressort hold up to jump the space
research
es gibt zwei tasten die man drücken muss
eine davon ist selbstmord wir kriegen
jetzt einfach mal auf enter um hier
zu sterben ja freunde die grafik ist
definitiv und ich bin schon wieder tot
die grafik könnte tatsächlich
er ahnt nicht wie schwer das ist man
muss genau aufpassen dann man wach du
heilige corp ich habe den dreh raus und
ich habe den checkpoint berührt meine
damen und herren jetzt da
laut check point falls ihr euch fragt
wie es aussah als ich damals schon mal
germany geben mir doch ich verlinke es
wieder mal hier da habe ich vor zehn
jahren mal mitgespielt da sage ich ja
noch ganz anders aus hat ganz anders
geschnitten apropos geschnitten ich habe
mich ja am finger geschnitten was eine
überleitung freunde jetzt schaffe ich es
da
habe ich jetzt ein checkpoint okay wenn
ich jetzt sterben wieder am start
ich habe ihn geholt hier seid meine
augenzeugen ich hab den checkpoint
es ist wirklich schlimmer als german
fashion nicht vom schwierigkeitsgrad
oder von der schnelligkeit sondern von
der gestaltung des spieles
da ist ein scheck vor doch nicht landet
genau auf dieses spiel das hier wird
definitiv das spiel des jahres was sorry
grad
ich habe gedrückt aber es ist halt
einfach komplett egal ob den ich habe
auf den checkpoint irgendwie keiner ist
und jetzt hier wieder weil darüber hier
auch das grüne tier drauf und darüber
und
war das jetzt wenigstens man checkpoints
wobei der studien checkpoint ja aber ist
ja komplett
so starte ich jetzt
am start am start
am start ich habe in meinem rad gerade
ca 17 checkpoints eingesammelt und 22
ziele erreicht und ich kriege es
trotzdem
dieses spiel ist unmöglich
ich bin schon wieder tot luca warum
spielzimmer so blöde spiele
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß echt nicht
ich habe echt ich bin tot
das traurige ist ich bin ein scheinen
noch immer kann ich auch vielleicht mal
woanders sterben ich bin glaube ich noch
immer in dem verdammten level 1 wo ich
es gibt auch übrigens gar keine tot
einfach toll dieses spiel hat nicht es
hat kein punktesystem ist hat keine
ranglisten es hat keine grafik es hat
keine checkpoints an diesem check point
steht ja was dran
da steht ja es bist b oder irgendwie
sowas ist mir nicht
espresso hold up to jump the space
escape to go bank
und was muss ich drücken um verdammten
checkpoint zu kriegen
oder um die entwickler umzubringen
wenigstens ist mein todes counter jetzt
zurück gesetzt das ist meine positiven
und ich bin schon wieder tot
mach ruhig doppelt so schnell einfach
einfach so nicht gedrückt
na klar ist ja das ist doch nicht wahr
ich habe nichts gedrückt und das game
wird einfach doppelt so schnell um ein
gott aber vielleicht könnte das ja mein
schlüssel zu mehr
viele fragen mich immer mehr
wieso ich diese pausen einlegen wenn ich
irgendwie im spiel sterbe das sind dann
einfach diese momente wo ich revue
passieren lasse warum spiele ich das
dann nämlich co2 sekunde nachdenken so
ja
es gibt keinen grund es standen nichts
in den steuerungen die man irgendwie das
spiel schneller macht bei mir ist es
trotzdem schneller was soll das denn an
alle die gerade noch dran sind
warum
schaltet weg bei andere youtuber wollen
dass ihre zuschauer möglich sagen
dranbleibt ich will einfach dass ihr
geht
ich habe ja echt jetzt am anfang habe
ich die ganzen züge raus wie ich hier
passen drücken muss damit ich diesen
grünen und dann bin ich wieder tot ich
mein stil mit euch ich gehe noch bis zu
60 toten und dann will ich ja was dann
passiert weiß ich noch nicht aber auf
jeden fall spiele ich nur noch bis 60
tote und bis dahin will ich verdammte
scheiße hier auf diesen grünen bereit
troja klar bitte ladet euch made with
games studio unlock jump jump box runter
und sag mir wie das geht
so eine scheiße gibt es von euch da
draußen irgend jemanden der sich mit
spielentwicklung auskennt wir vielleicht
ganz ganz cool wenn einer so ein spiel
machen würde wo ich dann darum lauf und
damit um kuli und balu und dann also
muss ja nicht krass sein kann ja auch so
eine scheiße wie jump oksana wenn da
irgend einer von euch ahnung von hat und
irgendwann gegen ebenso in 2-3 stunden
sondern so eingängigen wie ich meine das
ist häufig aufwendig oder ist schwer
sonntag wenn das einer hinkriegt dann
könnt ihr das eher meine kommentare
schreiben dann können ja die anderen
zuschauer in der community können ja
dann mal hoch wurden und dann werde ich
das spiel vielleicht mal spielen das
wäre dann vielleicht noch ein bisschen
unterhaltsam weil ich habe mich selbst
steuern wir doch nicht ja klar wir sind
bei 60 toten
das hier ist mein letzter dran meine
lieben freunde
mit diesem können die geschichte der
jump kochbücher einzugehen nicht wo mein
gott meine fans kann